I think like for a second episode it's
getting better all right it's what are
you doing I don't get it that you can't
walk on that what tell me you have no
problem walking on that flimsy thing
does that look safe to you
yeah what's perfectly fine picture this
is you're walking along minding your own
business then out of nowhere a sidewalk
rate is right in your path you think
yourself okay it was unsafe I'd probably
hear more about people falling in right
so you take that step you take a leap of
faith one step good good
you see no problem when that's secondly
your strain in the middle it breaks it's
old and you plummet never to be seen or
heard from again
that's literally never crossed my mind
once you are crazy all right you got to
know this one basements but you're
afraid of basements now let afraid of
basements what do you think I am I'm
talking about the stair scenario you
gave it a name
any time you head down to the basement
there's that unavoidable feeling of fear
that creeps back up on you when you head
up the stairs here annoys your heart
starts racing each step each Creek you
feel like something's approaching you
start having this conversation with
yourself right like chill out man you're
fine but the more you try to make light
of it the more you feel like you're some
horrible cliche back maybe forgot to
turn light off [ __ ] you flick the light
off as fast you can't running up those
stairs never looking back
you start leaping jumping skipping steps
you just barely make it up to that door
and then slam it or whatever God for
certain creatures like down there
waiting for that one day that one time
when you're not fascinated all right
everybody knows about the foot dangle so
you're telling me you've never heard
about tell me what it is so when you're
sitting on your bed and you're flicking
through Instagram or whatever and then
you think back to all those movies that
terrifies you as a kid or there's
something under the bed and a person
completely unaware that this demonic
thing is inching closer and closer think
yourself that's crazy
but you know what you still get your
feet out of there up on the bed and even
though you know it's totally irrational
you feel better dude you've never felt
that way before come on I think you've
seen way too many scary movies ever been
sitting on the toilet and you think
yourself what if something just crawled
up right now and just they're doing a
business and you start to think to
yourself do we really know what's going
on in this plumbing
I mean sewers breed all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] rats snakes alligators you start to
tense up a bit which of course doesn't
help with the current situation what the
hell is that noise you force yourself to
look down there you nothing deep breath
wait a second you jump up into my chest
in time to avoid the mutant snake
monster hardly for your I get it good
this stuff happens man doesn't
unfairness